The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
JULIAN BEINART:
First of all, we did
case studies of five cities with
reference to the 19th century
primarily, and how
they dealt with similar
of the fundamentals change.
Any thoughts before we move on?
Any comparisons
that strike you--
London, Paris, Barcelona,
Vienna, and Chicago?
AUDIENCE: I think it's
interesting with Paris
and Vienna how their
interventions were, in the end,
more integrated and sort of on
top of what was there before,
whereas Chicago is was
all new, and Barcelona--
you have a medieval city and
then the Cerdá plan as two
completely separate.
JULIAN BEINART: Yeah.
Yeah.
The Cerdá model, as I argued, is
probably the most conventional
model.
That is you leave the center
of the city and its walls,
where you take down the walls
because everybody took down
the walls.
The taking down of the walls
in Barcelona was before
Cerdá's competition.
So it was really moving in
the direction of expansion.
But the scale of Cerdá's
expansion plan is phenomenal.
How it is that the
city, model city,
would undertake such an
enormous expansion under such
a rigid control is remarkable.
It puts Barcelona in a
category almost all of its own.
Chicago's expansion
was from 1830 onwards.
You built a house.
You built another house.
There was no city involvement
in the expansion of Chicago.
It was purely a market
driven phenomenon.
AUDIENCE: But wasn't
the grid where
you could build that
house already established
through the government
division of land?
JULIAN BEINART: Well, I didn't
know the history well enough
to know what is
government subdivision.
It's a tract of land which is
developed by a developer often
according to--
the weakness of
Chicago's governance
is significant in the history.
It separated out completely
from the other cities.
European urban control is
a much more significant
than American urban control.
[INAUDIBLE] has argued that
the American layout often
included larger pieces of
land than was required.
And this he argued,
was a good investment
in that you could then double
up or expand over time.
Seeing how only half
the lot was built,
you could double up the
density for instance.
I did a studio
project many years
ago here in
Cambridgeport, where I
argued that one could densify
without changing the existing
buildings.
That there was
enough space to do--
and the reality of the
situation is that Cambridgeport
is absolutely resistant to any
plan which is densifies it's
area for one reason mainly--
automobile traffic.
You cannot in Newton, if you
have built yourself a palace
and have half another lot
free, you cannot even rent out
another property because of the
fear of an increase in density
automobiles.
AUDIENCE: But that is changing.
I mean slowly, but the fight
over laneway housing is going--
JULIAN BEINART:
It may over time--
I don't know whether
ownership of property
sets up a greater lack
of indulgence in change.
Pullman, Illinois
was an example of him
not wanting to let home
ownership exist because he felt
that home ownership would
stand in the way of the people
changing their
psychological apparatus
and living much cleaner lives--
as he is a paternalist--
were unwanted.
I don't know.
I was just reading
again about EUR.
Do you know EUR--
1942?
Michaela, you know
what EUR stands for.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JULIAN BEINART: Yeah.
Exposizione Universale Roma.
EUR was intended as a fascist
commemoration exposition
20 years after the
origins of fascism
in Italy and the Mussolini.
Anyway, we'll deal
later with this.
I want to now shift
gears a bit and do
three classes which reflect
backwards on these case
studies.
The first one today deals with
a very difficult proposition.
And that is the
expression of power.
The second one, on Thursday,
will deal with utopianism
because the 19th century was a
very hotbed of utopian attempts
to change the form and
social structure of cities.
And thirdly, I will
conclude this section
by looking at England--
the New Towne's proposition
in England after the '46 war--
and Russia between
1917 and 1932--
pre-Stalinist Russia--
as examples of attempts
to counter the problems
that the 19th century
city provided in a sense.
I think the material
I'm doing today
and the next two classes
suggests much more interaction
with you.
I would want your
opinion on things
which I'm going to propose--
difficult things.
Things which are very
difficult to establish in fact.
I start off with a quotation.
"In 16th century Paris a
popular form of entertainment
was cat burning,
In which a cat was
hoisted on a sling on a stage
and slowly lowered into a fire.
According to historian
Norman Davies,
the spectators, including
Kings and Queens,
shrieked with laughter as the
animal was howling in pain
was singed till roasted
and finally demolished.
Such sadism would be
unspeakable in today."
Another French example,
"Damiens, the incompetent
would be assassin of
Louis XV--" Louis XV
was an incompetent man himself.
He had an incompetent
assassin, Damiens.
"He was sentenced to be
torn to pieces by 6 horses,
to be stabbed and
have his wounds
soiled with burning
sulfur and molten lead,
and a good deal more
in the same vein."
Why don't we do that anymore?
According to the best writer
on the subject, Michel Foucault
in his book
Discipline and Punish,
we have substituted hard
measures for soft measures.
And in his view, soft measures
introduced by liberal society
where punishment is less
obvious and less brutal
is nevertheless curtailing
our freedom in society.
So let's look at that
proposition a little more.
Let's look at the proposition
of the facade in architecture.
And then let's look
at two case studies.
The one of the proposed
five mile rebuilding
of the center of Berlin
by Albert Speer and Hitler
in which we find some very
interesting components
of ideology which one might
relate to fascism or not.
And the other example is
the 2 1/2 mile Avenue in St.
Petersburg in Russia.
The Nevsky Prospekt named
after Alexander Nevsky who
was a 19-year-old
leader of Russia,
defeated the invading forces
from the North many years ago.
So let's start with this
soft replacement of the hard
with the soft.
Let's look at first
order a couple
of characteristic of
the 19th century which
appear in these cases.
First of all, the
Enlightenment is--
and of people as individuals--
the specialization of places.
The work which shows how
the integrated house--
which include craftsmen,
families, and all together
in the medieval Guild--
was replaced by separate rooms
and typologies of houses--
a special places for servants--
upstairs, downstairs,
in the British movies--
warehouses for workers,
and most importantly,
separation of work and home.
The journey to work
becomes a phenomenon
of contemporary society.
It's still is.
In the land of the salt mining,
salt processing town of Chaux--
C-H-A-U-X-- built in the
late 18th century in France,
you will see there are houses
for blue collar workers
and houses for white
collar workers.
There is a typology
associated with each.
And Ledoux designed Chaux--
the architect of
the Ancien Régime.
I would show you a house for an
intellectual that he designed.
Imagine conceiving of a project
of a house for an intellectual.
There is a typology
associated with each category
of human beings.
The concept of
typology has stuck
with architectural thought.
It's been revived
in our own times,
but in a different
kind of sense.
When we talk about
Aldo Rossi, we
will go back into the
contemporary meaning
of the typological experiment.
A second characteristic
of 19th century space
was the organization
of complex space.
The census in 1801 in England
used the cadastral system
for measuring land--
maps of boundaries and
ownership, specialized sewage
plants, and the capacity
of a new management
to organize complex space.
Thirdly, new forms
for institutions--
here we go back to our
story about punishment.
Fire no longer
needs to be violent.
Killing no longer needs to
be seen symbolic in public.
The guillotine is used for the
last time in 1789, I think,
more or less.
Torture is no longer visible.
Well yeah, I'm generalizing.
Modern society
attempts to teach you
to reform and change your habits
rather than persecuting you.
In order to do that, you have
the new idea of panopticism.
Panopticism being a
system where an individual
is watched from a
central position,
but doesn't know when he
or she is being watched.
A series of louvers
separates the prisoners.
The prisoners are isolated
from each other so they cannot
communicate.
The prisoners are either
workers, schoolboys, or madmen.
Light enters from the outside,
and creates a silhouette
which allows the person
doing the envisioning to see
the person being watched.
I quote from Foucault,
"The prisoner is seen,
but he does not see.
He's the object of
information, never
a subject in communication.
Power should be visible,
but unverifiable.
Institutions can now move
forward from being dungeons,
to being light structures.
A new prison preserves
only the enclosure,
but eliminates the need to
deprive the patients of light
or to hide them.
No bars, no chains,
no heavy locks--
fortress-like architecture is
replaced by economic geometry.
This is parallel with
taking down the city walls."
You know what a
panoptagon looks like?
I've just described it in words.
Shall I draw it on a--
can you imagine what this is--
yeah, of course.
I'm sorry, I forget
what I'm doing.
There are many variations.
Those are two from
Mexico, I think.
Elaborate structures
all maintaining
a certain central idea.
That you can watch a patient
or schoolboy or prisoner
without locking him up in the
sense of using every instrument
for preserving his security.
According to Foucault, this
creates an environment in which
institutions of health,
institutions of production--
I will talk about the
salt extraction city
Chaux near Switzerland,
1775, 1779--
and so on and so on.
Foucault uses the analogy of
what happens during the plague.
This is a fairly long.
I'm going to go through
it very quickly.
When the plague
appears in a town
at the end of the
17th century, first
the strict spatial partition,
the closing of the town
and its outlying
districts, prohibition
to leave the town
on pain of death,
the killing of
all stray animals,
the division of the town
to district quarters each
governed by an attendant.
Each street is-- and
he goes on and on
about the details of
how food is distributed,
the powers of each street
superintendent, death
is often the
punishment inflicted
on somebody who doesn't obey.
It is a segmented,
immobile, frozen space--
each individually
fixed in his place.
And if he moves, he does
so at the risk of his life,
contagion, or punishment.
He analogizes this was
the panopticon space.
This enclosed segmented
space observed
at every point in which the
individuals are inserted
in a fixed place, in which
the slightest movements are
supervised, in which
all events are recorded,
in which an uninterrupted
work of writing
links the center and periphery.
Power is exercised
without division
according to a continuous
hierarchical figure.
All this constitutes
a compact model
of the disciplinary mechanism.
It's [INAUDIBLE] that
the possible outcomes
of contravening the orthodox
environment of the plague
superimposed upon a place--
if he moves he does so at the
risk of his life, contagion,
or punishment--
three awful results.
In the sense that
when it requires
a specialization of types, as
well as a sense of geometry
of control, one can
find no better example
than the salt extraction
factory at Chaux.
I draw it on here--
actually only two
or three blocks--
the gate and the director's
house are on axis.
The geometry is that the
director, with his gaze--
here is he-- over the workers
who live on the edges.
Nobody knows whether the
director is watching or not.
The trick is that
you're constantly
under the threat of
being supervised.
The gate is decorated on the
outside, not on the inside.
What that means I don't know.
AUDIENCE: The decoration
isn't for the workers?
JULIAN BEINART:
No, the decoration
is for whoever gazes
from the outside.
Blue collar workers--
sorry, reverse--
white collar workers,
blue collar workers--
this is a crude diagram
of a factory town.
One of the first factory
towns ever built. In fact,
it may be the
first one on record
prior to the 18th century.
Have you seen this plan before?
Where do you run into it?
AUDIENCE: I think I
stayed in this same town.
JULIAN BEINART: Yeah.
So you have a typology
of specialized space
for categories of people.
You know this typology in
a location in the dormitory
for the director.
You have the automatic, constant
and subtle examination process
by the director.
These could be a bunch
of children being watched
in a laboratory through a screen
which makes them not realize
that they're being watched.
Oh sorry, the louver
system would be here.
The light would
reflect the people back
to the central observer.
OK, enough bad drawing.
We will see in the pictures some
more detailed examples of Chaux
A French contemporary writer
by the name of Paul Virilio I
don't know if you've ever
run into any of his writing,
he extend this notion of
inconspicuous examination
to the contemporary city.
If you want an
example of somebody
who's applied it to
the American city,
there's a thesis done in 1989
by Daniel Glenn called The Moral
Society, Inclusion, Exclusion,
and Control in the Urban
Center.
I think he does a case study
of the John Hancock building,
and a couple of examples of
where insidious control is
maintained whilst done in a
very elegant signifying way.
Virilio writes a piece
called The Overexposed
City which I'm not sure
I agree with completely.
But he says that we should
be conscious of the fact
that our behavior is now
examined and processed
through environmental
controls, which
are subtle and not so obvious.
Take the question of
congestion control.
Congestion control implies that
your movement in an automobile
has to be rationed.
Therefore you pay a fee when
you pass a cordon of a kind.
That fee is processed
by virtue of you having
some identification tag on your
car-- electronic identification
tag on your car.
It happens on the
Mass Turnpike--
if you live beyond the Mass
Turnpike entrance into city.
The objection to
congestion pricing
has often been that it locates
you in space without you being
aware that it's happening.
If a telephone bill arrives
at home, and your wife says,
I see that you were on
the main road in the city
and at 2 o'clock in the
morning of Thursday the 22nd.
What were you doing there?
And you stumble
and say, well, I--
it's a mistake.
I wasn't there.
The truth is I was
visiting my girlfriend.
It's a set of controls which
can be elaborated enormously,
and deprive you of your
individual liberty.
That issue will continue to
exert its force on the control
system.
The amount of freedom
that we will give up
in order for us to
maintain a sane environment
is at the issue.
I remember being on a
small group here at MIT
where one of the famous
computer control people
was on the panel.
And he made the statement
of the following kind--
he could reduce murder in
the society by at least 50%
by having everybody forcibly
wear a bracelet which
located them in space.
The fact that you can locate
yourself freely in space
is, of course, subverted by
a control system of a kind.
But a liberal control system
will not maintain your position
in space as a record.
Some of you may not care
whether your movements are
controlled, in space or not.
The payoff of the declining
rate of murder to the extent
that everybody who commits a
murder can be located in space.
It's an intriguing trade off.
And the modern city is
going to increasingly--
the modern society--
Virilio are and others--
Foucault amongst
others-- argues that it's
going to become a more
and more pervasive
phenomenon in the
contemporary city.
These are maybe symbolic as
well as actual phenomena.
I go on to another
aspect of the story.
And that's a piece of
writing by David Friedman who
is a Professor here in
the the history area.
Friedman argues that
the medieval street
was a functioning street.
In other words,
that it maintained
the processes of
commerce, expansion
of individuals into the
street, random affairs,
loose furniture.
A whole range of
things characterized
the medieval street.
Not only with the
medieval street,
the street of multi-use,
its facades which
enclosed the street were
democratized and varied
It is not until the Renaissance
that street and palace--
and this statement
is also true for
modest domestic
architecture-- were
set into the more or less
symbiotic relationship which
they continue until
the 20th century.
What he's saying is
the word fachada--
the facade of a
building or a street
plays the same expressive
role as the head does
in the human body,
it is the face
of what you see and
implies meanings
which the street is meant to
produce towards its users.
There were rules in
the medieval street
system for how many
movable objects to allow
to attach to a house or shop.
Movable tables or carts are
potentially so disruptive
to the social committee
order, were explicitly
banned later on.
We still make arrangements
around the use of a street--
in Italian streets, in
Italian piazza in summer.
In this country we
have now introduced
the possibility of doing it
even in the city of Boston.
Prior to recently it was
not possible to do it
in Boston because of
health related legislation.
Only a place could only
be considered healthy
if it maintained certain
proprietary sanitary laws.
Now there is a relationship
possible between the use
of the street as
a temporary device
while maintaining the
facade of the street.
There are transactions.
For instance, on the relatively
new hotel on the waterfront
is an arrangement
whereby the hotel
looks after that park
that's been created.
In return of which,
it may serve drinks
on the terrace outside
its own property.
The emergence of a facade
as a factor is interesting.
It promotes the expression
of meaning differently
from improperly
organized environment.
Rather than loose furniture, it
was also possible above 10 feet
to project your
house into the street
itself to gain more space.
So there was a
variety of disruptions
in the medieval street
to the constant orthodoxy
of the street.
Orthodox of the street
being non-facade driven.
According to Friedman,
this changed.
You have for the first time,
the organization of the street
facade largely for palaces and
large domestic environments,
as being constant.
He cites the 1444 Medici
Palace in Florence--
recognized as the first great
palace of the Renaissance.
He goes on to argue
about it's effect.
Facade then represents
a new relationship
with buildings in the city.
It is a concept born
in the 14th century
and matured in the Renaissance.
He argues, if he's correct,
in a changed identification
of the effect of the built
world on individual behavior.
Aztecs of the Street of
the Dead in Teotihuacan
didn't have constant
facades, but they
had pyramids of the
moon and the sun
and the strict notions of
behavior along an axis.
The projects-- the
two projects which
I want to look at with
you use the Friedman idea
of the facade as a powerful
tool in different ways.
Hitler's ideology
was in part based
on the permanence of power.
The EUR in 1942 under Mussolini,
was merely an exhibition.
It later became a
town or part of Rome--
the Southeast part of Rome.
Under Hitler there was no end
to the permanence of power.
Power was constant
and everlasting.
There's a wonderful
story that Speer
tells of working in Nuremberg
and seeing a building being
taken down, and looking
at the ruins, and saying,
we must not have
ruins as ugly as this.
So he invent something called
the theory of ruined value.
Imagine a theory which
forces you to make sure
that the permanence
of your situation
is going to be beyond
the life of the building.
That the ruins will ruin
like great ruins of Caracalla
or the great Roman ruins.
This is only one
example of a ideology
which is not temporary, but
which is seen to be permanent.
The style of buildings is
considered to be neo empire.
Again, it's got to do with
everlasting circumstance.
According to Speer, they
start with the Doric order
and keep on inventing new
orders as they go along.
Again, Hitler is the
beginning of a continuity.
Hitler himself says
to Albert Speer, whom
he chooses as his architect when
Speer is 26 or 24 or something,
he says I need somebody who
will understand when I'm dead.
Meaning again, that the
normal projection of nature--
of life, death,
ruin, and change--
is disestablished.
There are a number
of examples of it.
Hitler hated glass.
Glass was too ephemeral.
The 1936 games were Hitler's
great international triumph.
And he had a stadium which he
was being modernized with glass
and so on.
He hated it and told them to
stop and put back the stone.
Speer, in his spare
time, designed a stadium
for 400,000 people, which is
an impossible artifact anyway.
You cannot have 400,000 people
in a place, and have them see.
The distances become too long.
But when Speer shows
Hitler this model,
Speer apologizes and says,
I'm sorry, Herr Fuhrer.
The Olympic games will not be
able to be held in this stadium
because I have changed
the base of the platform.
So that the games, according to
the rules, will have to change.
Hitler says, don't worry.
The 1944 games are
supposed to be in Tokyo.
After that they will
return to Berlin
and be held here forever.
Forever, meaning forever--
meaning and at the same time,
of course, we will
change the Olympic rules.
We will change the
process in order
to secure the fundamental
fact of the construction.
So you get his
ideology expressed
in terms of an interminable
notion of continuity.
No end is in sight.
This is manic.
It's anti-natural.
We strive like hell
to keep things going.
But none of us have [INAUDIBLE]
and ideas about infinite time
unless we are so obsessed
with the inability to control
nature, such as death.
The second set of relationships
between spatial performance
and the physical form--
special performance
resonating with this ideology--
is the comparison system.
Speer constantly talks
about comparing things.
He talks about a project
he's doing Hitler which
is 2,300 feet by 3,400 feet.
He says, oh well,
Darius the first--
one of the great
rulers of Persia--
I forget the first
century BC probably--
only had 1,500 feet by 800 feet.
He says, we will erect a tower.
Nero had a tower of 119 feet.
The Statue of
Liberty is 151 feet.
Our Hitler statue
will be 197 feet.
When Leni Riefenstahl, who
made the great film Olympia
asked for more
money from Goebbels,
and then Hitler was
a great protagonist
that they make this film.
She said, look 1932 Olympic
games were in Los Angeles.
That's where Hollywood
controls the world of film.
They couldn't make a movie.
All they did was
still photographs.
We need to show the world
that we are superior.
And she made this
extraordinary film.
The film starts off--
has anybody seen Olympia?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: A lot of
the techniques she
used the triumph of the film.
JULIAN BEINART: Yes.
Yes.
One of the interesting
things too is the--
what is the other?
Oh, my mind just slips.
I'll think of it in a while.
This comparison notion-- there
was also ideology in the film.
The film starts in with pictures
of static sculptures, which
slowly start moving,
and they turn
into a running trip between
Olympia in Greece and Berlin.
The first carrying of the flame
ever in the Olympic games--
modern Olympic games.
That represents not only a move
from an alien world of Greece
to the modern Aryan
world of Hitler,
but it also indicates
a connection
in the film between why
Hitler has the Shepherd, who
won the marathon in 1896
in the Athens games,
on the stand with him in
'36 when he opens the games.
The ideology of this
regime is amazing.
It is consistent and
very adventurous.
Speer became the
minister of munitions
towards the end of the
war, and talks in his book
about the relationship
between how much money it
costs to build and how much
money it costs to destroy.
It's interesting, again, that he
would put that into perspective
as the Reich was declining,
and it was clear to him
that they were going to fail.
Another comparison, which
is interesting-- comparisons
go on forever.
One of the major buildings
in the North axis
of the new center for
Berlin is a domed hall.
This domed hall is 825 feet
diameter, which is colossal.
St. Peter's would fit
into it a couple of times.
150,000 people could be
accommodated standing--
how do you get such a size?
Well, Hitler thought it
necessary to explain to me
that the size of
the meeting hall
should be governed by
medieval conceptions.
in.
The cathedral town of
[INAUDIBLE],, for instance,
in southern Germany, 30,000
square feet of area--
when there were only 15,000
people living in all.
He used that relationship--
150,000 people for a size hall
for a city of a few million
people is absolutely correct.
There's a tendency in
professional practice
to constantly demonstrate
relationships.
I do it all the time.
I'm embarrassed often
when I'm doing it.
I'll say this is 3/4 of the
length of the last highway
which was built under
Roosevelt or whatever.
It establishes for
your clients a kind
of sense of location in time.
It's often foolish.
What is the relationship
between Eisenhower's building
of roads and the modern road.
But comparisons have a
funny kind of effect.
They stabilize.
They put you in touch
with a realm larger
than your own realm.
Often that's, for a fascist,
a great achievement.
Hitler speaks
elegantly of his visits
to the Vienna Opera
when he was a student.
He talks about gone is the
interior of the French opera
when he visits Paris in 1940.
This is the constant
notion that if you
are in a position of power,
you have to not only relate
yourself to other people you've
been in a position of power,
but you have to exceed them.
There's an algorithm which moves
in the direction of larger,
better, different, more
powerful, and so on.
So Nazism was as much--
the ideology as expressed
in spatial terms
was as much to do with
an evolutionary idea
that we are here to change time.
We are here to
influence time, and we
are going to do it through
spatial comparison.
If you look at this
map, there are large--
150,000-- technologists
have done some--
Hitler actually put
down the foundations
for some of these buildings.
And environmental
engineers now calculate
that this domed building with
150,000, 180,000 people in,
it would start raining inside
the building because of the--
it would have to be
air conditioned to take
care of the advent of rain.
You see some curious things.
There are cinemas.
There are opera houses.
There are concert
halls all spread
throughout-- from this
railway station in the bottom,
through the Triumphal Arch which
was borrowed from Napoleon,
but many times
bigger than Napoleon.
There's millions of
signatures on it.
There's a philharmonic hall.
Berlin still as the best
Philharmonic orchestra
in the world.
The Reich's opera is next door.
There's a hotel-- there are
various number of hotels.
There are restaurants
and museums.
There's a large amount of
culture built into the system.
Except for residents
and industry,
it virtually produces
all the forms of a town--
all the uses of a town.
What's wrong with this?
Could you imagine this being
built, and after the war
the ruler is imprisoned or dies.
And this is taken over by a
new liberal city of Berlin.
And Starbucks is
located somewhere.
And the Pritzker hotel
family are in here somewhere.
We reuse elements
of our special world
which have punished
people in the past.
We think very little
of taking an old prison
and modifying it into
residential accommodation today
although there's a little
bit of a stigma attached.
But there's no stigma attached
to taking Christian church
and making it into a
restaurant in Newton.
So transformability is possible
under all circumstances.
Could something at
this five mile scale
be transformed over time--
partially in part?
Could a personality environment
ever be changed formally.
You go to one of the buildings
in the world I like most,
The Ducal Palace in Urbino,
if you go into the basement,
you see the qualities
that the servants
must have endured in crushing
ice for this great Ducal
family.
I don't evaluate
the Ducal Palace
on the basis of the tragic
condition of the labor which
must keep the place in order.
So what are your standards?
Memory plays a part in this.
Memory.
is kept alive through
monuments, memorials.
We'll do a class on memory
later on in this class
because it's become a much
more interesting aspect
of this discourse.
There's no memory
embedded in this project.
Shingle is not reintroduced
or played upon spatially.
It's an ultimate
controlled environment.
For Jews and gay people
and gypsies and others
who suffered enormously under
the process of this regime,
it's difficult to talk
about this without involving
procedural questions.
There's a wonderful book in
the Holocaust literature on--
gosh, what's the town--
death camp in Poland on the--
AUDIENCE: Buchenwald,
Auschwitz, Dachau
JULIAN BEINART: No,
it's not one of those.
It's far to the East.
It's-- oh, Christ.
AUDIENCE: Treblinka?
JULIAN BEINART: Treblinka.
Treblinka.
There's a book by a man called
Steiner whose parents died
in Treblinka.
He interviewed some
of the old people
who escaped from Treblinka
towards the end of its life.
And he asked the question,
which is often asked
of the Jews, why
they didn't rebel,
why they just took it all.
And he tells the
story of this being
the phenomena in Treblinka
until a certain point,
around 1940 or
somewhere, where they
started worrying that maybe
the Nazi regime was not
going to survive.
And they started
taking down buildings,
rebuilding them as parks--
planting grass, putting
up hedges, planting trees.
And the Jews, at that point,
couldn't take it any longer.
They were afraid that the
memory of the death situation
would not be--
there would be no evidence.
And on that basis, they
engineered the first revolt--
most were killed.
So the whole issue
of memory, how long
it can maintain itself, is the
memory of this building system
separable from the memory
of the ideology which
perpetrated death?
These are questions
of meaning, which are
very difficult to deal with.
Let's look briefly,
very briefly,
at the regime of St. Petersburg.
St. Petersburg--
the Nevsky Prospekt
is one arm of three
spokes which emanate
from the center at the water.
You've got a plan
in front of you.
The plan is anchored at its
beginning by 2 connections.
The one to the symmetry
of Alexander Nevsky,
the 19-year-old who
saved Russia in 1240
from invasion from the North.
The other one is to the
interior of Moscow--
to the interior of
Russia and Moscow.
The axis on which the building
ends is the Admiralty building.
Peter was obsessed
with water and ships.
When he became czar toward
the end of the 18th century,
he tried to build a
Russian fleet which
could then go down the
Volga towards the Black Sea.
He was beaten up and failed.
He then turned to Europe.
And this was one
of his openings--
to Europe he shifted.
He never liked Moscow
because like Louis XV,
one of his relatives was killed
in Moscow in the Kremlin.
He then did one of the most
manic things ever done--
let's try to build a
city the equivalent of it
North would be like
the United States
like building its
capital on Hudson Bay.
It's so far North,
the word [INAUDIBLE]
is a swamp in Finnish.
Hundreds of thousands of
people died in the building
of this strange city.
He had to impose taxes on
people entering the city,
that they had to carry
stones with them.
It's a remarkable story.
It's axis between the water,
the admiralty building,
and the history of Russia.
They are two crossing
water bodies--
the Fontanka and the Moika.
The Moika is where, in one
of the days of the 1917
revolution, the mob
came down the street,
and there were Russian
czarist military
waiting for them at this point.
And in a significant
gesture, the Russian military
didn't fire on the mob.
There is today a
cinema on that point
called the [INAUDIBLE] Cinema.
So this is an
environment much older
than Hitler's, but where
time has already intervened
and changed the use.
Many of the great palaces--
the Belozersky Palace.
the Stroganoff Palace,
the Mikhailovskiy Palace
are now museums.
St. Petersburg has
a higher proportion
of square footage in
museums as opposed
to population than any
city in the world--
largely because they take over
so many of the great palaces
under Sovietism.
The water is
constantly a factor.
There's a bypass on the left
close to the Fontanka river
back to the water.
There's another one close
to Dvortsovaya Square
where the road gives as
a bypass to the water.
On the building of the
public library, the Duma,
which is the city hall, the
Kazan Church, a bookstore,
a lady's store the Passage,
the Holland Church --
almost everything that
you-- the Alexander Theater,
public library, so on.
What about Alexander Nevsky?
Peter the Great tsar
was a cruel man.
He imposed no liberty on
his civilian population.
He built a city
at enormous cost.
Nevsky Prospekt,
unlike Hitler's, is
anchored in Russian history.
It's modern history related
to the water and to--
Alexander built the
beginnings of the Russian army
and the Russian Navy.
It's another-- first of all,
it has mixed uses on it.
Well, so does Hitler's.
I just spoke about the number of
cinemas and performance halls.
So that doesn't distinguish.
What distinguishes between
the two roads as expressions?
The reference to
Hitler's practice--
ideological practice renders his
treatment of the center Berlin
highly suspect.
You cannot divorce the two.
Over time who knows what will
happen to the memory of Hitler.
In another 100 years our future
will be as much of a building
to be visited by the great,
great, great, great, great,
great, great, great
grandchildren of the people
who died.
This is the first panopticon
of Bentham, the British liberal
who considered the idea.
Plan for shipyard's-- again
where controlling system
emanates from a
central position.
Lecture on the
evils of alcoholism
in the auditorium
of Fresnes Prison.
Here is a prison in Illinois.
Not many American panopticon
prisons were built. Next.
Mexico seemed to be keen--
the revised panopticon on the
right is a national stamp.
Next.
Chaux, the original plans--
Arch of Saline on
the left and right.
Next.
The [INAUDIBLE]---- the
fact that you can see
the director's house at the back
at the same time as you enter--
a connection between the two.
Next.
Decoration of the
director's house.
Next.
And these are two
other projects.
This is a house for
an intellectual.
Again, the typological exhibit
for a character consideration
of a person as a type.
What is different between a
house for an intellectual--
other than you may
have a large library--
and any other house?
Here is a maison de plaisir--
a kind of pleasure palace--
again, with a kind of
centripetal organization.
Next.
The extension of this idea--
this is a hospital in Paris
as it's grown over time--
added on to by piece
by piece by piece.
This is a computation
entry for rebuilding of it.
Now there are two
dominant forces.
The one is the
church at the top.
The other one is the
entry at the bottom.
Everything else is
segmented and fixed in place
and open to observation.
Behavior is now frozen as
it is in the panopticon.
Next.
Same device for
children's school
and an example of the
separation of house and work.
Each being a domain,
which is individually
separated from the other.
Next.
Hitler did much of
drawing himself.
Here he's in Paris, late
1940, with Speer next to him.
Next.
"Did This Art Student's
Failure Change History?"
Well, yes.
This is Hitler's own drawing
of the large domed hall.
Next.
The Arch of Triumph--
the axis to the doomed
hall, and this 400
foot wide avenue on either side.
A good decoration to the
avenue, wall of guns.
Next.
You've got them.
OK.
Hitler's sketch of
the Triumphal Arch.
He could draw quite well.
Next.
Nevsky Prospekt, the
yellow stripe on the--
leading from the admiralty
building to Alexander Nevsky.
The other two spokes added
later lead to the barricades,
to the army.
OK.
Next.
We'll go for a walk
down this street.
This is the Nevsky Prospekt
with the admiralty building
at the end--
day and night.
Next.
This is the Railway
Station Hotel to Moscow
to the center of the country.
Next.
A small church which is
turned into a subway stop.
Next.
A Fontanka water crossing--
the Menshikov
Palace on the left--
Next.
The Belozersky Palace,
the Passage store--
Next.
It is Alexander Library--
this is Alexander Library on
a small road which leads off
the Prospekt to the water.
Next.
The Duma-- the central
city headquarters.
Next.
The Duma-- I'm sorry, this
is the Kazan Cathedral.
Next.
I just give you a sense of the
enclosure-- the facade, next.
The Moika crossing,
[INAUDIBLE] Cinema,
a bypass to the Dvortsovaya
Square on the right.
Next.
Dostoevsky said,
St. Petersburg is
the most intentional and
abstract city in history.
Dostoevsky was in
prison across the river.
I'll start on Thursday
finishing this story--
just raising some questions
about what this all means.